hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to sort the court now in
this game I'm a king
and now just king of the squirrels I'm
actually king of a people in a far-off
land and I have to sit on my throne
I guess the music's done now ok ok there
we go and the music's back so I'm a king
in a far-off land I have to sit on my
throne and answer the questions or
requests of my horrifyingly disgusting
people and hope to help them stay alive
and not die and maybe food little bit
not much we don't have much to spare so
without further ado here comes King
markiplier coming in hello hi royal
adviser Lord I'll help you rule your
kingdom but you have to make tough
choices just say yes or no understand no
good very funny
just give people their answers ok
alright thank you
the city's not what it used to be there
were over 250 people living here think
things will ever be like that again no
no no no you'll need to be more
confident than that let's get started I
don't know about this
I'm the horribly depressed Oh God hi I'm
hungry can I eat some folks I've got
plenty of gold so I can pay you back for
their lives
he's got goals I mean what could you're
wrong how about no how about no oh [ __ ]
no leave them alone oh thank you thank
you for not devouring me instead
jeez bye hello hi how's it going my
leaves there's a man in the for year
asking to join your God he's got an
eyepatch looks a little shifty he's got
an eyepatch does that mean he's a pirate
and if so I want a pirate on my guard
hell yeah what do you think we should do
to take a chance yeah of course we
should indeed more swords will help us
indeed I think I'm doing good oh hey I
was considering opening up a soup shop
think it's a good idea I'd need some
gold oh grandma soup it would be cruel
of me to say no to Grandma
really one - all right fine you can open
your soup shot oh that was a lot of gold
holy [ __ ] very well I'll sell my soup in
the towns what second that was like a
quarter of my gold grandma highway
robbery
alright bye grandma have a good one I
guess it's night now
oh hey I was just passing through and
thought you might like some magic
anything could happen
care to give it a try I like to take
risks let's do it yeah all right this is
going wonderfully for me I'm not doing
terribly which is a big change for my
life darn aliquots okay thank you
Wow I can open more grandma stalls that
sounds weird they're not stalls selling
grandma or not in that other way that
they would be selling grandma no it's
grandma soup stalls so I did pretty good
I don't know what the comparison to do
good or bad I wish to construct a tavern
but I'll need some gold from yes more
whoa a couple hundred but then the
people have beer they can get drunk yes
let the peel [ __ ]
the townspeople will be happy to have
well that did a lot less than grandmas
soup and grandmas soup was always fifty
gold
[ __ ] you ah well that's no good that
didn't do me any good to the hello it's
just staring at me does it want
something I hope not but I'm gonna go
with my gut and say that it does yes ah
no I feel unlucky but I started out so
good this game started out so good and
now it's gonna take it all away from me
yeah looks like you want somebody to pat
his belly no yes no yes no yes no yes no
yes no yes no how can I turn that down
oh okay okay
what did it turn into a person how did
that work
oh no that's happiness excuse me that's
happiness hmm you call this a castle no
no I don't know I don't know who you
should be more confident
oh [ __ ] you ha ha how's that for
confidence Monsieur you love it fine
Baga oh hello I've got a friend from
Witte school looking to move to town
could I get a couple gold to help remove
in well is it good to have more witches
how would I know
sure why not oh well that was easy
well that wasn't much at all good it's
going wonderfully so far except for the
little hiccup there a lot of lost well
but that's not my fault
people are happy in the city is growing
yeah the city's growing people are happy
oh boy ok that's good so now people oh
that's awesome
hello I've got a business proposition
for you and your tiny little town are
you interested huh this all depends on
whether or not I like foreigners and the
answer is yes I do
ah I will bring you details soon okay
have fun with your bird on your head
good bye oh hi a little fatty
care to gaze into my magical vampire
crystal huh that seems like a bad idea
but I'm a risk taker let's do it
yeah whoa I see fame and fortune for you
yay for risks go out there and take a
bunch of risks everybody don't do that
maybe do that I don't know
take a chance I don't know who oh I wish
to put on a show may have the funds to
do so how much funds I don't have a lot
of funds left I I've got very little not
funds yes well they didn't do anything
you just took my gold Moo this cat seems
slightly magical not sure what it wants
though yes yes pancake oh I guess that's
good okay but well I mean I'm doing good
on how hi grandma the soup shops been
doing well I came to offer you some of
her oh thank you oh thank you grandma
oh that investment is paying back in
dividends oh thank you the gesture show
was loved by the court and put everyone
in a happy mood yeah awesome oh that's
cool
we're growing yay it's still good right
have you seen my magical cat pancake yes
I have I patted his bail bail oh very
good I knew he was around here somewhere
not sure where though off to wander in
the woods forever hello I'd like to
build a new granary this could help
expand her I don't have much money yes
that's all I got Oh God
you got this you got it this will help
our city grow well I do I'm out of gold
oh hi
and you need a cash I could hook you up
if you let me eat a few folks how about
it I do have folks to spare a good
sacrifice of you but no I will not stoop
so low
get out of here yeah I'll find some
other way you go on get out of here okay
hello hello hey seems you need some gold
I could give you some in exchange for a
few souls
nay nay I say I
Sydnei to Chester I'll say no to you
Georgie suppose you have to look
somewhere else for coin then yeah I will
and this is that is that Chester from
don't starve hi Chester what what no
what do I have to choose between the two
of you how is this in any way good well
the people are growing cities growing
still I guess we're doing fine the
Treasury is empty my lord we could raise
taxes but the people won't like it much
should we try
well yeah better than them getting eaten
yes oh that's ah but good ok it's
something that we can live with I
suppose I mean what can you do
hi I was just passing through and
thought you could care trasher please be
good yes it's good oh thank you thank
you thank you travelling wizard yo any
mysteries of hood I can do some snooping
for a small fee if you're interested how
small it better be tiny I mean I'm not
one to trust a skeleton but here we go
oh good ok you'll uncover the truth
thank you I don't know what truth you're
talking about hi oh one of our prisoners
escaped may I have some gold offer a
reward for her recapture it's a shifty
eye patch man he's not a pirate at all
but yes how much 50 oh come on all right
cool
at least I got some happiness back who
the hell are you my boats too tiny to
catch fish can I have some gold upgrade
it I'll pay you back I swear I trust you
you look trustworthy with that beard I
can't help but not oh God oh please
we're still growing Oh God whew it's a
build again Oh
no no go away go away yeah you leave him
alone Chester you turned evil at one
point in your life hello Monsieur Mouton
allo sir are you looking for experienced
barbers in your court sure my beard is
growing rather unruly so maybe yes then
I shall join you I'm the best of the
best huh
did you assemble your clothes out of the
hair of the Fallen okay goodbye oh hello
hello friend sure it turned out great
last time I'm sure it'll go great this
time whoa nice is that just randomly
generated or is that the same way every
time
that's good question you find me
humorous yes haha okay goodbye
alright see you around okay some
villagers are threatening to leave
unless we pay a sum of gold should we
listen to their demands no screw up I
see we'll let them go we didn't want
them anyway they weren't a good part of
society if they're demanding gold to
live here then they're now welcome here
so says I the king hey and we got more
people there anyway all right so we're
doing okay oh hello again
a caravan of mine wishes to camp in your
city for the next few days might that be
arranged sure that'll bring trade for
everybody okay bye oh grandma
oh thank you grandma you're so nice oh
you're so nice grandma thank you so much
oh hello can you have two of course you
can have some food little buddy only two
gold for a happiness Oh tricked-out
nobody all right bye-bye
hello No
No I'll get you next gen buddy all right
sure you will with your sassy button
sassy tail hello my friend from which
school wanted to thank you for your help
so we made you some magical cookies Oh
are they weed cookies
the Sultan's Caravan is resting in town
or citizens have been trading with them
producing a small amount of tax income
yes this is going beautifully cool oh
the cast is almost done in the
background who I would like some money
please now here's a life lesson for
everyone out there never judge a book by
its appearance cover say yes oh god oh
god no a hundred go hood a hundred oh
hey it's slime day got a present for me
no [ __ ] off yeah get out of here what
who cares if it's slime day I wasn't
told about this oh yes please please
give me some good magic please oh thank
you oh it went well I don't know how you
magically spawned in more people
although I can imagine how we've been
awarded with a trophy ooh yay okay
that's good
need to make the city even bigger but
it's already at maximum bigness hello oh
yes of course I will
all right bye bye Bootsie bah bah boo -
bah bah boo - oh that's awesome
I've got so much money oh that's nice
people are happy good good good go the
[ __ ] away Georgie Jourdain no Georgie
[ __ ] off you all get me next time you
won't what
uhh
ha no how about no I'm gonna whole lot
of no how about how about Georgie
how about Georgie you go you go away you
go away back to wherever the hell you
came from oh hi plants are interesting
don't you think I would like to open a
garden may have some workers to help me
yeah sure
are you gonna consume them oh god you
ate them sure you'll send them back okay
Oh grandma oh no you can keep it grandma
have it for yourself oh thank you
grandma
thank you I'll uh hey Horning in I just
figured out a mysterious way - new way
to make gold one know how sure not
telling you okay thank you thank you
looky good we're doing wonderfully I
don't even know if there's an end of
this game I've got a business
proposition
oh is interest leaping through the other
stuff Thank You Sultan I think we got it
I think we won I'm not sure oh there's a
party I'd like to go to this evening
might I have the rest of the day off no
no you work for me okay fine yeah sure
whatever go on you're Barney thank you
we will toast to your honor
oh I guess they will she doesn't say a
monkey has been running around flinging
stuff at them should we put a bounty on
it I mean the monkeys just doing what
monkeys do best but sure let's put up
let's put a price on the head of that
monkey oh not kill it oh okay all right
that's probably for the best
Oh mom says I need to ask your
permission to go on an adventure so can
I please please
okay is your mom gonna come back angrily
when you die sure God have fun have fun
out there
don't die yeah I'm hungry no no there's
a petition going around to open our
borders to the neighboring town what do
you say sure
bring him in more people whoa together
alright okay I can deal with that thank
you I guess
he's going whoa who are you want me to
steal from the rich and give to you not
just rich I'll steal from you ever oh
thanks okay bye have a good one bye you
Paju say oh you're cute
yeah I've been talking to Skelly have
you uh oh here take this I was never
here okay okay thank you
honesty is its own reward plus a whole
heap of gold yeah [ __ ] him get him out
of here we don't want him anyway
can't keep him in the town against their
will anyways what's the point
oh oh oh thank you oh say you actually
paid me back I can't believe that oh
that's awesome
we're doing so good I don't know what
else to do really cost one sandwich no
that's my sandwich and you can't have it
all right fine have a sandwich you're
excited to eat this I'm less excited
that I said yes I gotta start saying no
to people asked us to form an alliance
should we use them to beef up a ranks
hell yeah I love some beefy ranks yeah
we're sort for us okay cool
oh god it's you it's nice it's user do
you like my new haircut no it doesn't
look any different yes
uh-huh you're welcome
you're welcome buddy you're welcome not
you again it's not slime day go away go
away
Iseult Ann okay thank you yes do that
yes No you evil bastard I trusted you
Wow three out of four ain't bad I guess
high Skelly you've got a skeleton of
your own you know you don't you find it
weird that you can't see it no not
really you don't think anything is weird
do you not not really have a good one
yeah huh uh hi Mortimer boy you've
changed how are you doing oh hey YouTube
oh one of your fishermen has been
bothering me I demand of Algeria as a
sacrifice how about no no you've angered
me wash your back what are you gonna
kill me the fisherman's got my back
hello
guards confiscated some gold can I have
the back no what you're keeping it but I
still okay hello
our granary has been infected how much
is that gonna cost
oh that's not bad oh okay Buda get the
escaped prisoner has been recaptured
thanks to the bounty okay our theater
than rest easy knowing she's been put
away is it that thief girl the spirits
are a piece right now but perhaps we
should grant them an offering of gold I
know the spirit world always appreciates
gold and it might prevent them from
haunting us in the future what do you
say 200 gold 200 200 I kind of want to
be haunted but sure okay we've got gold
despair
I'll conduct a ceremony and offer this
to the spirit world
okay all right oh baby gay on the
blacksmith I'd like to shut up shop just
need your permission okay go ahead have
fun
all right Oh God not this thing just
staring at me doesn't want something no
it doesn't get away oh god damn it
that's not fair there's no way to win
that hello the owner of the tavern are
making piles of gold and wish to share
some with you well ain't that lovely of
them gramma can you borrow a coin for a
news of course you can grandma of course
you're welcome grandma grandma is so
nice I hope it doesn't turn out to be
like the cookie clicker grandma's where
there horrific evil
it's that slightly magical cat from
before does it mean we're friends now
yeah
hope so oh yeah
a little guy Oh oh hi but number then
boom boom yeah you got you got the best
rhythm bro you got the bestest all right
have a good one
the people have started a petition to
ban pineapples in the city should we do
I love pineapples no I love pineapples I
love pineapple
we'll never give it up could I trouble
you I gave you a sandwich before you
little second all right
fine have a sandwich you stupid piece of
crap but if you ask me for another
goddamn sandwich I'm not gonna be too
happy about it next time god damn it
this [ __ ] yeah whatever
oh hey oh thank you Oh who are you
the blacksmith has crafted me a
legendary sword may have permission to
wield it in the name of our kingdom sure
whoever you are I don't know exactly who
but good
my lord a man wishes to settle a dispute
he says he is way cool but his friend
says not do you think he's cool
well I haven't seen this person how can
I wait maybe it's like something you
feel like this guy sounds pretty cool
but I mean why would he be cool if his
friends say he's not cool well you know
what I say you are what you want to be
so he's as cool as they come I'm sure
he'll be happy to hear about that I was
the most important decision of my day I
Skelly I found a way to summon people
from another dimension yeah okay all
right okay I'm gonna complain oh this
was a bad day hi I told you I told you
I'd be back your people will be my um
snack see how about no no you dared to
define me I'll eat you all uh who's
going poorly hello would you like to
purchase any swords yes please thank you
all right
hello King I'm a tree of the Western
forests as you can see however I've been
shortened actions of team of wood
cutters my arm has been chopped clean
through in your reckless pursuit of
expansion you have now disrupted the
lives of myself and other good tree folk
and brothers and sisters I demand
compensation by the way of golden coins
so that we may repair this
how shall I pull this diplomatic rip
1000 we shall go to war with the tree
folk before I pay you that money
this is development which will be surely
met with the distaste in the community
of tree folk your refusal to cooperate
compounded with your woodcutters
aggressions has driven me to the peak of
anger
rest assured King I will not be silent
this destruction you a fraud on my kin
will be known to all
we needed to build high whoa what is a
strange place I found myself in Albert
do you know where we are
my oh my hello kingly person I do
believe I'm a bit lost mad I stay in
this town for a while sure starting to
get weird in here how nice Albert and I
shall shining into Stan I'm sure I'll
see you again Albert seems to like you
thanks Albert hello yay yay oh man oh
thank you
let's keep working hard okay hopefully
I'll thank you trusted advisor I'm a
good king the town we made an alliance
is in trouble so we send soldiers to
system yeah I mean we do have a
rampaging army of spirits and Treefolk
headed our way but sure okay of course
we promised yeah I keep my promises
hello yes of course Winston people need
to stop that
Oh workers at a construction site
arrived in the morning to find all their
lover stolen setting work back by weeks
a tree trunk led a protest in the square
against woodland destruction guards had
to be called to settle things and they
demanded overtime pay papers have been
posed around town spreading news of the
destruction of Western for its people
quiet feel quite guilty spooky spirits
oh this is getting bad I don't know how
much longer this game is gonna go maybe
it just gets progressively harder and
harder to keep it going whoa squee
there's a mouse should we chase it no
it's a smart Mouse he's got a booking
glasses of course 9 why would you it
would be so cruel hello again
captured some foes on the battlefield
should we bring them home and put them
to work as slave mmm let's not go down
that road no thank you
we need to do something with them shall
we ransom the captured foes off I like
gold and I like gold okay I like gold
alright sounds good to me
I'm okay with that couldn't let him go
free but that would have been good at
all
all right fine I've said no to you just
give me the gold they won't even know
what hit him we stole from our own
people but that's besides the point not
important I'm hungry can I see some
folks sure world were populated anyway
you're eating people regardless so yeah
hey oh that doesn't seem good at least
they're not unhappy oh boo give me your
gold or all your townspeople no my gold
but I want my gold
how many townspeople are we talking here
I just let someone else eat them for
gold so are we talking about all of them
why am I even debating this is something
about me that I'm debating this yeah
Oh God haha yes I'll take that okay
thank you goodbye hey
children's dreams are being invaded by
ghosts and spooks haunting is quite
frightful oh man
sir I heard about the dragon attack you
were made to endure I've come up with an
idea to strike back I can craft a blade
powerful enough to slay the dragon and
take all his treasures it won't be easy
though need to track down the finest
materials few hundred gold yeah sure we
need a show okay you need to show their
dragon who's Mars my lord I've come
across it yes yes oh not enough I was
hoping for more but thank you sir about
the dragon blade yes that's what I'm
calling the sword now I purchased
top-quality materials but I need a few
workers yes spare all the workers you
need we shall have a magnificent blade
and hopefully when we kill the dragon
that's gonna be like the last thing that
we do tax the merchants hell yeah hell
yeah tax those merchants we need the
money
oh hello again I've returned not with
how cause prepare yourself for a protest
of unimaginable proportions
I am rooted I will not budge from this
spot until you answer for your crimes
against my people your workers have
wounded our way of life things will
never be the same in the forest
what say you will you first at least
admit to your Countryman's wrongdoing no
I don't think so I think we did the
right thing I we needed the wood and
then you know you know what can we do no
but a great petrified fine
you twig minded sapling you're rooted
firmly in denial my soft bark friend
your refusal to indulge it even the
basis of courtesies betrays her
tyrannical nature although I cannot say
I did not expect this
you humans never change always looking
out for only yourselves okay bye
it's finally done finish crafting the
dragon blade all we need now is somebody
to wield it spread the word to our
heroes if they wish to take out the
blade I'll send them here can we kill
them
oh I'm back alright sure but you're not
gonna take my dragon blade you're not
don't you dare my lord might I be the
one to take up the dragon blade and slay
the dragon yes
you my friend are good you're gonna do
it you better do it you friggin better
to go hello yeah I can sure give me all
of your exposed wires and I'll fix you
right up
I am become fixed you are not smart but
you are robot okay oh hey I'm truly
sorry about earlier my circuits weren't
quite fried my circuits work right fried
I offer my thanks for your help thank
you
ooh quite logical thank you have a good
one oh hello Annabelle abby'll bond
George is finished moving in Anna system
on my own may I have but one person sure
but why do you need an assistant who are
you
the council of science has devised a
blueprint for a gold generating machine
it will take some time to construct a
many resource but if calculates produce
gold steadily for the rest of eternity
500 don't have 500 gold balls more I'm
betting you're not even gonna say
anything as you walk away yeah
all right we did it
scientists come back oh man we finally
did it okay that is the end of sort the
court hi uh no I'm not go away okay so
that is the end of sort the court I've
been playing this for about an hour I
don't think there is an end to this game
but if there is maybe you can find it on
your own you can play this game for
yourself through the link in the
description below and let me know what
you thought of it it's kind of a cool
game it was made for the Ludum dare game
jam and not too bad so thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye
do you know how to get us